you or someone you know may have type 1
diabetes this video will show you some
treatment options your doctor may
prescribe to help manage it
if you have type 1 diabetes your goal is
to keep your blood glucose or sugar
within a normal range your doctor may
suggest a combination of insulin therapy
other medicines
checking your blood sugar
eating a healthy diet
and getting regular exercise
because your pancreas doesn't make
enough for any insulin you will need to
take insulin it will replace what your
body should be making
professional can train you to inject the
insulin just under the skin you may need
to give yourself injections several
times each day and you will need to
rotate between injection sites this
helps avoid damage to your tissues and
helps make sure you get the best results
from your insulin
another way to get insulin is through an
insulin pump the pump is attached to
your body and sends insulin through a
tube that is just under your skin
your pancreas may not be making enough
of a chemical called amylin normally
amylin helps control your blood sugar
level by reducing the amount of sugar
your liver makes during a meal it also
slows the movement of food through your
stomach so your body doesn't take it in
as fast if your body isn't making enough
amylin there are medicines to replace it
how much medication you need will depend
on the level of sugar in your blood you
will need to check the level of sugar in
your blood with a glucometer ask your
doctor how often to check
to do this you will prick your finger
with a small needle called a Lancet
then you will place a drop of blood in
the glucometer following the directions
provided with your glucometer knowing
your blood sugar level allows you to
adjust your insulin dose
the calories you eat during meals
and physical activity as directed by
your health care provider
your treatment plan includes eating a
healthy diet and getting regular
exercise they will help you manage your
sugar level and may help reduce your
risk of complications from type one
diabetes
it is important to take your medications
as directed by your doctor do not go off
your medication unless your doctor tells
you to do so tell him or her about any
side effects you may have